i want to start with the most exciting
thing because i just read about it
yesterday which is like the whole king
of the hill i don't want to pressure you
or anything but i just have one question
which is um i read a while ago that you
guys were um thinking about bringing it
back but it would take place like a few
years after
the original series where the characters
might be a little more or a little older
is that still the case
um well you know here's the weird thing
about that
the way that article ran is is uh
there isn't any change yet we don't have
a deal to do it um i'm not exactly sure
if we phrased it wrong maybe um
but
it's still not 100
so
but um the idea is is uh currently the
idea is
um a time jump yeah so it is um the
the the characters are a bit older yeah
but again like it's not 100
so
is it one of these things where you guys
want to do it and you guys have to sort
of work out the contracts with like fox
and everybody well we haven't worked out
the contracts yet um
and uh you know we we had the idea
floating around that we pitched a while
ago um
and you know i think we we need to
figure out how we would
do it well and um
you know and who would do it with us
because we're both pretty you know busy
yeah also there's something else with
the ability now to maybe do shorter
seasons you know maybe doing like six
episodes or ten episodes
instead of twenty something might be
more appealing in this day and age
well i'll tell you the truth about that
is
uh it depends on who you are
like if you're
a writer on a staff
um
you know you are paid on a weekly basis
and there's some downsides to
um
working the short
seasons because it's hard to kind of go
up the ladder
you know like the old the old time but
um
you know if you're if you're a show
runner uh or you consider that you're
responsible for the outcome
um you know it takes forever and you
don't have any help because the writers
are all they all disperse
you know once the writing's done
and you know in the old days when it was
a 22 episode 25 episode season
everybody worked there continuously you
know and they got a little break in the
summer but
everything was on top of each other so
you had a lot of people to delegate to
so you could be like all right you go to
the mix i'll stay in the room for next
week you go down to the set and see
what's happening
you know but with the short orders
your writers are gone
and all of the stuff about the set and
post and there's nobody to help really
so
so the great thing about this season of
space force for me was i had my old
friend norm hiscock join me
on the show runner level so he was there
the whole time so i had somebody to to
talk to in all the you know the mix and
the music spotting and the
shooting and everything like that but
you know when you don't when you don't
have somebody there at that level then
they just disperse
so it's actually kind of hard to have
these short orders
in one sense you know you don't you're
doing everything yourself or whoever the
show runner is
i actually never thought of it like that
um i just have to ask you also uh being
friends with mike have you pitched him
on your beavis and butthead idea and are
you trying to write an episode
i haven't i love beaverson by head as
the fan um
you know
but i uh that's his thing i'm not i'm
not gonna jump in there